research helps us to seek the truth
to solve our social or scientific
problems
and to find meaning in our lives through
creative activities
most important research will become a
critical element
to help guide nevada's economic recovery
we are grateful for the support from our
governor
nevada state legislature and all our
generous
donors and hope they will continue to
invest
in our commitment to research excellence
as the cornerstone
of unlv both for the benefit
of our students and for the people of
the entire state
our leader in this mission dr
keith e whitfield is a highly esteemed
scholar and researcher he is the 11th
president of the of unlv and former
provost
and senior vice president of academic
affairs
and a professor of psychology at wayne
state university
he received a ba in psychology
from the college of santa fe and m.a and
phd degrees
in lifespan development psychology from
texas tech university
and did post doctoral work in
quantitative genetics
at the university of colorado boulder
president whitfield is a champion of
student
and faculty success innovatorship
and interdisciplinary research his
broad higher education experience
includes developing programs
and institutional policies that promote
social and economic equity
and financial stability he has also
devoted a considerable amount of time to
faculty development
particularly for junior scholars
dr whitfield remains an active scholar
his research examines the etiology of
individual variation in health and
individual differences
in cognition due to health conditions
dr whitfield works with researchers from
sweden
russia finland and the united states
he has been continuously funded
researcher
for more than 20 years through nia
nih and nsf with projects totaling
more than 18 million and has authored
or co-authored over 200 articles
books and book chapters his current
research
project focuses on the relationship
between
stress and longevity in african-american
families in north carolina
it has been my privilege to work closely
with president whitfield
over the last several months and during
a
very very unique academic year he has
kept us on track to what
is most important the success of our
students
unlv is very fortunate that president
whitfield
was willing to take on the enormous task
of leading this university
and keeping us moving forward in a
positive direction
he is a warm and caring individual
strategic thinker and an avid champion
for unlv
please join me in thanking
our president of unlv dr keith e
whitfield
for the state of the university address
president whitfield thank you so much
vicki
i'd also like to thank the entire
faculty senate for your support since my
arrival at unlv last august
i hold shared governance as critical to
great universities
and you and your colleagues are the
epitome of that philosophy
and special thanks to former president
martibiana for
all her support and work well hello
colleagues
students alumni supporters and
dignitaries
wow what a year we've just completed
i've been in higher education for more
than three decades and i cannot recall a
more challenging time
maybe everyone can say that particularly
in twenty twenty
but these are unusual times for sure
i've never shied away from a challenge
though nor has the university
they say that smooth seas don't make
skillful sailors
i'm so proud of how unlv faculty staff
students and administrators pull
together adjusted
and successfully fulfilled our mission
during a tumultuous past year
while this period has been
unconventional and disruptive at times
we've persevered and risen to the
occasion i know it's not been easy
whether you've been working from home
teaching remotely
or working on campus thank you for your
passion and dedication
to supporting and pursuing higher
education
and it's just further reinforces my
decision to come to this great
university
unlv is uniquely positioned for
long-term success
now that doesn't mean that there's not
work to do or that we're perfect
but there's so much good here and so
much has been achieved over the last
several years
my job along with all of you is to build
on that success
to make what's already great even better
nationally this past year's generated
much discussion about how higher
education
will evolve and how it will emerge from
this pandemic
i believe public urban research
universities like ours
are the pillars that will support the
future of higher education
we have the ability to weather the
so-called 2026
cliff of declining enrollments better
than most of our counterparts
that's because we draw from a large
centralized population base
and it's more than that public urban
research universities are situated in
major metropolitan areas
and have more opportunities to develop
partnerships and become integrated into
economic and community issues
and we're seeing that firsthand here at
unlv as the university recently ranked
within the top 10 percent
for social mobility for our graduates
this index
by college net rates all four-year us
colleges and universities based on how
they effectively
enroll students from under-resourced
backgrounds
and graduate them into well-paying jobs
simply put unlv provides an opportunity
for people to change their lives
and the lives of their families we also
help address community issues
and there's perhaps no better example of
that than the coven 19 pandemic
and the role the university has played
and is playing and will play
to support the region and the state this
includes both fighting the virus
and helping pull the state from the
economic downturn
nearly every college and school at unlv
has been involved
from the arts to the sciences and this
is especially true
of our schools of public health nursing
medicine
integrated health sciences dental
medicine and the colleges of education
and sciences
as well as the student wellness center
and the practice we've partnered with
the state of nevada
clark county southern nevada health
district
university medical center clark county
school district
and the business community at large
mitigate monitor and navigate coven 19.
our efforts have included counseling
contact tracing
testing and now vaccinating creating
test files and personal protective
equipment have also been some of our
efforts
offering services to emergency
responders serving
as first responders or health care
support staff
and tutoring young children while their
parents are working our schools of
medicine opened one of the first
testing locations during the earliest
days of the pandemic
and now they and the school of nursing
are helping lead the effort to vaccinate
many in our community
the same is true for our school of
public health which has trained
200 students through a grant from the
state
to perform much-needed contact tracing
and epidemiologist brian labis
has provided critical counseling as a
member of the governor's advisory
committee
these are perfect examples of how our
university can build community within
las vegas
it means being a resource applying our
expertise
and partnering to address issues in the
community where we all live
and work building a community
also has an inward focus as many of you
are aware
i spent a good portion of time on a
listening tour
during my first few months on the job i
wanted to hear what our faculty
staff students and community members
think about unlv
i learned how truly dedicated people are
at unlv
and how great this university is but i
also heard some frustration
some sadness and some anger there's now
a summary of those conversations posted
on the website
building a community which actively
ensures that everyone on campus feels
welcome
and heard is an area of concentration
for university leadership
we will continue to acknowledge and
address cultural issues at our
university
cultural though sounds like a giant
amalgamation of
colleges and departments with
i would argue that interpersonal
interactions that happen between
students and their instructors how
faculty talk to other faculty
how administrative or professional staff
interact with classified staff
or even how vice presidents or deans
treat their staff and faculty
and their university president of course
we need to develop a culture that is
more equitable and fair
one that's more inclusive and one where
everyone feels like they have the same
opportunity
or at least an equal voice to be heard
we need to feel comfortable having these
discussions and not become defensive
irritable threatened or scared
it means that we need to have grace
grace in part is admitting when we're
wrong
and allowing others to admit when
they're wrong in a non-threatening and
safe
space when we create that culture
and when we come together in this way we
can achieve great ambitious goals
it's only then that we can build a
campus community
that's fully healthy and flourishing
that won't happen quickly
and we'll never be perfect we do have
our need to strive to be better
to do better and not to punish ourselves
when we make mistakes
i want us to set our sights high as a
university
we cannot limit ourselves to only what
we've seen
or fear what we've not yet done or tried
before
we have to imagine a better place now
failure is always a real possibility and
it's only human
to try to avoid it but fear of failure
limits our ability to do great things
it makes us believe we are limited by
what we see
and how we are at this moment i
challenge us
not to fear what we are yet to be
we need to embrace change because it
makes us better
i'm often reminded that i'm the first
black president
in the sixth this university
the fact that you hired me means that we
can change
i believe that the regents the faculty
and students
supported my nomination because they saw
the content of my character
not just the color of my skin and while
i'm the first
i certainly hope that i'm not the last
we have to direct our focus
on how we are making change for the
betterment of all our students
your co-workers and your fellow faculty
we need to dream of an even greater
university
over the next decade five years ago this
university embarked on a top-tier
journey
that would elevate the university to be
recognized as a top public research
university
in the country related conversations
started decades ago
and continued until they crystallized
into a functional plan
capturing critically important goals to
set our sights on
i have great respect for my predecessors
and to the faculty and others
who have dedicated precious time energy
and resources
to move that vision forward we have made
remarkable progress on our journey
and in december of 2018 the university
achieved a major milestone
when it was recognized as a carnegie r1
or
very high research university the gold
standard among colleges and universities
only three percent of colleges and
universities in the country
are included in the carnegie r1 ranking
so it's bolstered the reputation and
brand of unlv
and in early 2020 we earned carnegie's
highest measure for community engagement
also a remarkable feat but these
achievements are only the beginning of
what we can accomplish
listening to you and seeing what we have
here
there's more we can do more we should do
and more we plan to do
we continually evaluate our top tier
plans and i believe it's time to expand
the plans
and mission i refer to this as top tier
2.0
it's the next evolution of our
aspiration to become an even
greater university or as i say making
great better
top tier 2.0 is rooted in the original
plan and still recognizes the importance
of our key metrics
around retention graduation rates
research expenditures
doctoral degrees granted non-faculty
researchers and postdocs
and community impact however it also
defines additional metrics
in the existing core areas and includes
new core goals
as well top tier 2.0 is a
forward-looking roadmap
that our university will continue to
refine and follow
over the next decade with respect to
student achievement
we've made market progress over the last
several years
but we need to continue to press onward
and keep aiming high
notably i would like to see our current
six-year graduation rate
increase to 60 percent by 2030.
it's a 16-point jump from our current
level to help get us there
we'll launch a student success
initiative that includes our ongoing
efforts to improve our advisor to
student ratio
from one advisor for each 515 students
to 1 in 350.
we'll also do some national benchmarking
defining best practices
and host a university-wide summit to get
everyone engaged on this critical goal
student success will become an element
of relevant
leadership evaluations i should note
that graduate student success
is integral to this expanded core goal
we need to bolster research scholarship
and creativity
to one include multiple inner and
cross-disciplinary programs
two create more interdisciplinary
centers and institutes
and three increase research and research
productivity
and beyond and lastly four provide
student research opportunities
at all levels at this time i want to
take a moment to highlight a couple of
research faculty
from the college of sciences who were
included in
science magazine's top 10 breakthroughs
of all of 2020.
physicist ashkan salamat's work on room
temperature
super connectivity and astrophysicist
bing zhang's
observation of fast radio bursts or
powerful radio waves coming from deep
space
in fact governor steve sisselak
mentioned ash's superconductivity work
in a state of the state address last
week and referenced how it translates to
energy efficiency
and economic diversification i can
honestly say
my research has never been called out by
a governor in a state of the state
address
wow ash that's really impressive
congratulations to you
and bing for your contributions to the
science community
and for strengthening the unlv brand
the academic health center also has been
a core goal outlined
in the original top tier strategic plan
and will build
a stronger structure to support its
development
as well as a process to identify
timelines milestones
and major benchmarks over the next 20
years to meet our long-term vision
the academic health center is not a
building
but a strategy that integrates and
leverages
the multiple health science disciplines
at unlv to provide
high value and high quality care for the
community
and medical research opportunities it
will also provide a key source of
economic diversity
for our economy we must continue to
foster
community partnerships and that includes
strengthening and expanding our
relationships with the clark county
school district for k-12
and with csn if first-time freshmen or
transfer students are better prepared
to have stronger skills when entering
unlv
they'll make the transition more easy
have greater success
one recent initiative in this area is
the rebel summer series
which our college of education
introduced last year
it's a five-week summer learning
opportunity for local students in grades
two through five
that offers web-based courses and
activities in science and literacy
community partnerships must also include
civic engagement
our community needs to help address the
homeless issue and food insecurity
that many including some of our students
experience
the work of the greenspun college of
urban affairs with the las vegas
sands and nevada partnership for
homeless youth to conduct research and
develop policy
addressing this issue is a perfect
illustration of how we can make a
difference
faculty and students in social work
criminal justice public policy and
leadership
and communication studies are all
involved in carrying out this program
similar efforts are occurring with the
city and county as well
and now for the new core goals in top
tier 2.0
economic development will have a more
front and center role
will pull economic development from its
previous shared pathway goal with
community partnerships
to distinguish its importance while also
broadening its scope
it will become an independent core goal
to stimulate
socioeconomic development this signifies
that we are engaging in these efforts
for all people
in all sectors in all classes and in all
neighborhoods
socioeconomic development includes a
focus on the research park
strengthening industry engagement and
advancing
entrepreneurship and innovation faculty
and students must be active participants
for us to move forward on this goal
because strong universities are vital to
the economic recovery
development and sustainability of
southern nevada
this is our home and i've seen the
commitment you all have to help it
thrive
the other new core goal is to promote
and support
a culture equity and inclusion
previously our top tier values have
alluded to these but bringing this focus
to the forefront
and further defining expectations will
create actionable items
we will cultivate an environment that is
inclusive
welcoming and supportive for all by
assessing and developing conditions
necessary for improvement
that includes things like leadership
accountability and assessment
programming to address unintentional
bias in search committees
faculty and staff mentoring programs to
promote success and emphasizing a
culture
and platforms where all faculty staff
and students can be heard well-known
researchers lee bowman and terrence deal
address culture in their work on
reframing organizations
it's perhaps the most difficult area for
an organization to change
and i know that this new goal may
generate some anxiety
maybe even some skepticism however
we need to realize our deficiencies and
acknowledge there's
inherent structural racism at this
university
we're not unique in that regard most
organizations have
some element of it and in most cases
structural racism
is unintentional and it may be something
as mundane as policies and practices
that impact people differently some may
ask
what does this have to do with
graduating students
but if we're going to reach the next
level
we need to realize and understand that
this is a challenge that needs to be
addressed at unlv 2
and as a major public research
university that has one of the most
diverse
undergraduate student bodies in the
country we should be a leader in this
area
it begins with not being afraid to
discuss it and making it a priority
earlier this week the faculty senate had
an honest
difficult conversation about issues with
diversity and inclusion at unlv
i applaud their insight and desire to
make changes
for a better university environment
faculty and staff
i'll be working with them to refine more
definite goals in this area
some of the programming and professional
development opportunities we need to
offer already exist
the unlv college of liberal arts offices
of diversity initiatives
and student diversity and social justice
in partnership with
the anti-defamation league and the
interfaith council of southern nevada
launched a series last spring that
addressed the effects of racism
on public health indigenous and land
justice
and issues of the first amendment unlv
libraries and the college of urban
affairs
also developed a panel discussion about
race-related media coverage
economics health care criminal justice
and education both series continue in
february during black history month
the anti-black racism task force and the
minority serving institution
or msi task force continue to do work in
this area as well
these are important steps forward we
will cultivate and develop more
finally in top tier 2.0 we will continue
to develop our infrastructure
while ensuring shared governance remains
at the heart
of all that we do but we will also
strategically deepen the culture of
philanthropy
and alumni connection to bolster our
financial sustainability
philanthropy is so important to
continued growth
and success as a university because it
provides the ability to support students
launch new ideas and to make already
great programs even better
three of the many recent examples
include a nine million dollar gift
from the san manuel band of mission
indians
to work with our law and hospitality
programs to develop
first of its kind programs in tribal
gaming law
a six million dollar commitment to
advance brain health
through the chambers grundy center for
transformative neuroscience
and a five million dollar gift from
panda express co-founders
andrew and peggy churn for the nation's
academic program in casual restaurant
management
now some of these strategies will
require organizational shifts
first as you may have seen earlier this
month i've elevated the position of
economic development
to vice president and that function will
be separated out
from the research division now is the
time to make this move because economic
development and diversification
will be critical for the state and the
region as we emerge from the pandemic
second the position of chief diversity
officer will report directly to me
and i'm reviving the ombuds office both
of these directives are designed to
provide a more defined avenue for
faculty staff and students
to voice their concerns or issues lastly
we will move forward with creating a
vice president for health affairs
that will advance collaboration among
the health sciences schools
and ensure the vision mission operations
and health care services are all
strategically aligned
i realize that this may all sound
aggressive given the times that we're in
one of the things that you'll frequently
hear from me say is that we need to make
a dollar out of 15 cents
i know how difficult the budget
situation has been at times and several
of you have mentioned
that we still haven't fully recovered
from the great recession of 2008.
i spent the better part of three decades
in higher education and i know that
budgets are always a challenge
for public urban research universities
we have been fortunate though
that our enrollment has held fairly
steady during this pandemic
and we must be prepared to capitalize on
and be a part of the economic recovery
our focus for the nevada state
legislature this upcoming session
will be on economic development and how
we can support the state
and our partnerships with the clark
county school district and k-12
education
we also want to reinforce the importance
of the medical education building
and the college of engineering building
i am so appreciative to governor sisolak
for including these capital projects in
its proposed
next biennium it's a bold decision
during unprecedented times i would
expect nothing less from our governor
and we will demonstrate that investing
in unlv
is good for everyone
it's been a busy five months and i can't
stop thinking morning day and night
about all the opportunities at unlv i
came here because i have tremendous
respect for this university
and each one of you but no one
individual can move this university
it takes a collective effort from all of
us and we need to realize that we may
fail at times along the way
but don't be afraid of failure learn
from it
build on it and grow from it i won't get
upset if we fail periodically trying
something new
only if we don't try at all we can't
have the attitude
because we've always done it that way
these times require
more innovative and entrepreneurial
thinking than ever before
now rebels aren't afraid to fail or
create a new path
when one doesn't exist i was drawn to
this university
because i identified with that spirit
that determination
that daring style we are all
unconventional independent tenacious and
resilient
that's a rebel our university our
community our society
has changed we need to be thoughtful
and to evaluate adjust and evolve
the decision announced last week to
formally retire the hay rep mascot
is an example i recognize the different
viewpoints on this topic
but we listened we learned and we made a
thoughtful decision
even if everyone doesn't agree as unlv
continues to rise as a top public
research university
we must do so in a way that represents
all of our students
staff and faculty my aspiration
is for unlv to become a premier research
university that's community focused and
world leading
for people from all socioeconomic groups
and backgrounds
can thrive a university that's caring
but practical a university that hears
all voices
and has a rich culture a university
where ideas
and opportunities in closing
i've learned the power of people can
move mountains change can happen
but it's in your hands we can be more
successful we can graduate more students
we can obtain more grants we can do
better in our neighborhood in our
community
we can make great even better but it
takes
all of us to get there thank you for
your dedication your ideas
and your continued hard work